uh we have been speculating about the
future
of the trump family with regard to
vaccination uh i'm sorry with regard to
investigation my mind is still uncovered
once donald trump is no longer president
of the united states
and we got some news that might be a
sort of a signal about what we are to
expect once donald trump is out of
office
and that's that a state judge ruled
yesterday that the trump organization
must turn over documents related to a
property
whose tax abatements are being
investigated by the new york attorney
general
um and and well will continue to be
investigated and these are
this is still going on these are
documents that the trump
organization this is trump's business
previously claimed
were protected by attorney-client
privilege and
a a judge has decided that that is not
the case the attorney general argued
these documents are not privileged
partially because the trump organization
waived
privilege when it disclosed certain
documents to the irs
to gain benefit and a judge agreed
and we've heard this story before and
many
will say hasn't this been ordered before
and they still haven't turned over the
documents and that
is true so what is the difference why do
we care about this
we care about this for for really two
primary reasons
number one soon donald trump is no
longer going to be president
and while it wasn't a big part of this
case
there are all sorts of other
investigations going on into donald
trump and his
business and his uh finances and his
family's finances
um and donald trump is soon not going to
be able to hide behind
i'm the president and this is a burden
because i am the president
that's something his lawyers have
frequently used to try to make the case
that he should be left alone
and they've done it to some degree of
success that opportunity goes away
in 35 days i believe it is and that's
going to change this
dramatically number two uh
the legal fees are going to become
outrageous even for trump
and not only is donald trump i mean
listen
he can keep trying to raise money for
for legal fees on the basis of
i don't know running and maybe that's
why he'll announce that he's running in
2024
to be able to raise money which he could
maybe legally maybe not
redirect to to legal fees even if that's
a violation of campaign finance law we
don't that's not clear yet
but we have this we have rumors that
donald trump
is absolutely horrified about the
possibility of being deposed
in the sexual assault case brought by e
jean carroll if that name rings a bell
it should
because we talked about her in 2016 and
2017 that was on hold
while donald trump was president he will
soon not be president
every indication that that story and
that case is going to come back in
and donald trump reportedly horrified
about maybe being deposed
in that case and these legal fees are
going to build
as the legal protections for trump as
president evaporate
and that could dramatically encumber
trump
over the next who knows how many years
so this could all get
really wild in the six to 12 months
after donald trump leaves office
we talked about starting to see the
light at the end of the tunnel as far as
the pandemic is concerned
i'm starting to see the light at the end
of the tunnel in terms of the trump
administration and
it's going to be a bad couple of months
in terms of the virus
it's going to be a chaotic couple of
months in terms of
the maga people and the cue and honors
having to adjust to this reality of joe
biden as president there's the
possibility of violence
we can never get back the lives lost due
to trump's mishandling of the virus etc
etc
but if you zoom out a little bit
vaccination has started trump is leaving
joe biden is coming in we have early
voting starting in georgia with
democrats still
possibly taking the senate and the
investigations into donald trump
are starting with numerous now favorable
decisions by judges
now will they ever get the documents
that the judge said have to be turned
over
maybe and the truth is that these
particular documents like this isn't
really even the bombshell case the point
here is
at some point trump is going to run out
of appeals
and or run out of run out of money for
appeals in terms of legal fees
and if and when that happens and i
believe it's more a matter of when
rather
than if uh this is going to become a
very complicated
2021 for donald trump very quickly make
sure you're following me
on twitter where you can find me at d
pacman
we're going to take a quick break and
it's really a packed show today this
let's actually keep a record of this one
because this one i think is going to be
pretty good
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed collar
that won't fall down and lay flat which
i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout